the second season of the umbrella
academy may have answered some of our
biggest lingering questions from season
one but it raised a bunch more of its
own
here are some of the biggest questions
we're still wondering about after
finishing the umbrella academy season 2.
in the first season of the umbrella
academy we meet the hargreaves siblings
mom
grace whom we quickly learn is actually
a robot however in season two diego runs
into grace again at a gala in 1963.
only this time she's a real flesh and
blood person
it turns out that grace is a scientist
dating reginald hargreaves the enigmatic
hargreaves family patriarch
and has no knowledge of any of his
shadier dealings diego urges grace to
look closer at a boyfriend's business in
dallas
telling her that reginald is planning to
assassinate the president
although grace insists that diego is
mistaken she does take his advice
and finds evidence of the assassination
conspiracy she confronts her griefs who
doesn't refute any of her suspicions
but tells her there are some parts of
his life he just can't discuss with her
someday i hope to share it all with you
until then i'm asking you to trust me
this doesn't seem to go over well with
grace the last we see of her she's
walking away
from reginald seemingly for good it
raises a lot of questions
including how the robot version of grace
eventually came into being in the
original timeline
and whether diego's interference has
changed grace's fate
season one of the umbrella academy
revealed that 43 babies were
spontaneously conceived
and birthed on october 1st 1989 and the
hargreaves only managed to adopt seven
that leaves 36 still out there somewhere
with the introduction of lila we get a
first glimpse of what might have
befallen some of those other children
like the hargreaves siblings lila had
super powers but said childhood was
markedly different from theirs
it begs the question of how many other
superpowered siblings are out there
if any of them have found one another
and why we haven't heard anything about
them yet
right on the heels of learning that she
is actually a long lost hargreaves
sibling
lyla grabs a briefcase and splits for
destinations unknown although luther
could have stopped her
diego intervenes admitting that he's
fallen in love with her but where did
lyla go with a commission briefcase she
could travel to literally any point in
history
and without a functional commission to
monitor her she could probably get away
with quite a lot will she go to 1993 to
attempt to save her parents from the
handler at number five
will she jump further into the future to
try to reunite with diego
one of the more poignant storylines from
season 1 revolved around the eccentric
klaus
accidentally spending several years
fighting in the vietnam war
during that time he fell in love with a
fellow soldier named dave who was
tragically killed in action
in season 2 though klaus sees another
chance to save dave when he finds
himself back in the 60s
this time several years before his first
trip back unfortunately klaus's plan
isn't very well thought out and he winds
up getting punched in the face for his
troubles
yet despite klaus's bumbling he does
actually manage to change something
i've already enlisted
what that's not supposed to happen yet
claus assumes this means he's doomed but
maybe not perhaps dave's earlier
enlistment date will lead to other
bigger changes down the line could klaus
actually have managed to save dave after
all
we don't know but we're holding out hope
when young harlan accidentally drowns
midway through season 2
vanya uses her newly rediscovered powers
to lift the water out of the lake and
revive him
during the process she inadvertently
passes some of her powers to him
although she doesn't realize it at the
time later vinya realizes harlan is
linked to her
and that her own trauma has triggered
his powers harlan's powers quickly
spiral out of control
and vania is ultimately able to calm
harlan enough to approach him
and draw his powers back into herself
also she thinks
at the end of the season harlan's mother
[ __ ] makes a hard choice to say
goodbye to vanya since she worries that
vania's abilities will put a target on
her back and would put harlan in danger
[ __ ] just wants a normal safe life for
her son and decides to take him to
california to start over
however the last time we see harlan he's
making a toy bird levitate in his hand
in the back seat of his mother's car
implying that vanya didn't drain all of
his powers after all
what other abilities does harlan still
have and how will those powers and his
traumatic experience in dallas help
shape the rest of his life
we hope to find out in season three one
of the other parts of the 1960's story
line is the cult klaus starts thanks to
his tendency to spout sung lyrics that
haven't been written yet as if their
prophecies
and his ability to use his dead brother
to perform seemingly impossible feats
egged on by klaus's own ego and aversion
to conflict clause's cult quickly winds
up taking on a life of its own and by
1963
he's amassed quite the following
although klaus does eventually attempt
to make things right
revealing to his followers that he's a
fraud before leaving with his siblings
to save the world and return to 2019
the cult members forsake his confession
for another pearl of enlightenment
despite klaus's departure the closing
moments of season 2
indicate that his cult is far from over
they're still driving around in a
rainbow-huge bus
picking up new acolytes along the way
it'll be interesting to see if the cults
are still around in 2019
how it has changed over the intervening
56 years and perhaps most intriguingly
how the group will react to the return
of their profit still looking exactly
the same as he did when he disappeared
in 1963.
when the hargreaves siblings arrived
back in 2019 they're shocked and
relieved to find both their father and
their previously deceived brother ben
are still alive but their excitement is
short-lived when neither
reginald hargreaves nor ben seem to have
any idea who they are
know what the umbrella academy is this
is the umbrella academy
wrong again this
is the sparrow academy the name change
is mystifying
since the umbrella academy was named for
the umbrella factory where hargreaves
set up sharp
shortly after arriving on earth he was
still operating out of this same
umbrella factory in the 1963 that the
hargreaves siblings departed before
jumping to 2019
so it's curious that the academy doesn't
bear its name could someone else have
named the sparrow academy
and if so what is their role in the
organization is hargreaves still in
charge or is he now reporting to someone
else and what significance does the name
sparrow hold we can't help but think
about how harlan ended
the season using his powers to levitate
to toy bird coincidence
we'll see check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite netflix shows
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one